if you're talking to Elon or you want to
have a conversation with Elon and you
get that opportunity to talk to Elon you
need to be concise quick there's
definitely uh 2 A.M texts and 6 a.m
conference calls when I used to go into
meetings with him I used to always stop
by our Barista and I would get a couple
espressos and chug that down and then go
into the meeting he's never said this
but I've watched it
um you have 30 seconds to make your
point Elon Musk is known by his
employees to be intense when he took
over Tesla in 2008 he sent the company
into crisis mode to jump start his
vision of how to reinvent the Auto
industry
now he appears to be using a similar
management Playbook to remake Twitter
we spoke with former Tesla and SpaceX
employees to better understand how musk
became known for his Cutthroat and
tireless management style and what that
may mean for his future employees
step one for musk is to Rally employees
around a lofty company Mission
exactly what inspired Carl Medlock to
join Tesla in 2009. we're all so excited
about the brand I mean we all working 80
100 hours a week we kind of lost track
of our families our our passions our
hobbies and all that stuff but we love
what we're doing I never once had Elon
or saw Elon do a rah-rah meeting like
that Medlock now runs his own electric
vehicle repair shop in Seattle he said
he was terminated from Tesla in 2013
over a misunderstanding with his direct
manager Garrett riesman was similarly
inspired by the mission of SpaceX and
joined in 2011. it's a very demanding
environment
but but by and large it's not because of
him cracking the whip you know making
human life multiplanetary getting to
Mars having a colony on Mars is
something that that motivates pretty
much everybody there it's Basics reason
left SpaceX in 2018 to teach
astronautical engineering at the
University of Southern California he
said that after seven years at SpaceX he
wanted to work somewhere less intense
yet at Twitter the mission isn't exactly
saving the world they are talking about
protecting Free Speech which of course
is important but it is not as dramatic
as trying to go to Mars Tim Higgins is a
tech and Automotive reporter for the
Wall Street Journal and author of power
play a book that traces the rise of
Tesla and Elon Musk well the challenge
that Elon is going to have at Twitter is
what are the stakes neither Elon Musk
nor Twitter responded to requests for
comment the company's mission is what
musk hopes will drive people to be
hardcore a term he uses to describe
working long hours at high intensity you
just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every week obviously people at two
o'clock in the morning because we
finished up an event and we were all
still energized because we're having
such a good time and musk has used this
idea of Hardcore to Rally his team over
the years as they approach hard
challenges for example in 2012 when
Tesla Was preparing to ramp up
production of the model S luxury sedan
musk sent his team an email with the
subject line Ultra Hardcore telling them
to prepare for a level of intensity that
most of them had never experienced
before about three weeks after taking
over at Twitter musk sent a similar
email but hundreds of employees opted to
leave the company rather than sign up
for musk's vision of Twitter 2.0 the
challenge here is Elon has inherited a
huge Workforce and he has to convince
them to be on team Elon and we're seeing
him try to go through those ranks of
people to find the talent that he's
going to need to Pivot the company to a
private Twitter and it's messy musk
himself leads by hardcore example I
sleep on the couch over there last time
I was here I actually stepped literally
on the floor because the couch is too
narrow I showed up at work early one day
and it was just me and him and one
security guy in the entire 5.5 million
square feet and I didn't know he was
there right and at the factory when when
you uh there's walkways and safety areas
and stuff like that when nobody's there
I just got on a bicycle riding around
and here Elon is asleep on this
engineer's desk in November musk tweeted
that he was sleeping at Twitter's
offices in San Francisco and it's not
just his time but his money how much did
you put into this company
oh man about 55 million dollars in 2008
when Tesla was at its darkest moment and
he put in his personal last millions of
dollars to fund it he was even you know
couch surfing in Menlo Park and paying
my business expenses with personal
credit card debt right his approach is
to do anything required to keep his
businesses competitive and he lived that
every single day when I worked for him
Conrad left Tesla in 2011 for Renault
Nissan Mitsubishi the people that I've
talked to with Elon talk about how he in
one hand is incredibly inspiring but on
the other hand a lot of people will say
he was also exhausting and Mercurial and
after a while they just couldn't keep up
with him there is also a history of
employees at Tesla and SpaceX alleging
misconduct at the companies musk is also
known to quickly make his companies
leaner when he became CEO of Tesla he
cut about 20 percent of the workforce a
about a week after he took over Twitter
musk laid off roughly 50 percent of the
staff according to a document seen by
the journal and people familiar with the
matter estimated that likely over 1 000
have resigned former employees have said
that this Cutthroat approach instills in
them this feeling that anyone working
for musk is the best of the best back in
the day at Tesla Elon would often say
that people who work for him are special
forces he wants to hire a key engineer
who in his mind has way more value than
say a hundred engineers and to deploy
those top talent on the hardest problems
and be able to move faster and not have
the same kind of level of bureaucracy
former employees have said that musk
avoids traditional corporate hierarchy
if Elon was interested in something you
were doing he would come and talk
directly to you he's not going to go
through a bunch of different layers of
management and have the information
filter up musk also motivates employees
to work harder by raising the financial
Stakes when Elon became CEO of Tesla the
account economy was in shambles it was
the Great Recession and there was huge
questions about whether people were
going to want to buy a luxury car and
not just a luxury car a luxury car that
was electric similarities to Twitter
today we've got an uncertain economy the
company needs to start generating more
money it has a huge debt load it has to
find its place in this social media
world that's under a lot of pressure as
the ad Market it kind of contracts in
November musk wrote in an email to
Twitter employees that without
significant subscription Revenue there
is a good chance Twitter will not
survive the upcoming economic downturn
musk is still in the early stages of
setting up his strategy for Twitter and
finding people he trusts to help him
transform the company that's Basics if
you proved yourself to be capable
Innovative especially on a technical
level then that led to very very rapid
advancement throughout the company if I
were an employee at Twitter right now
I'd probably just do your job
don't let them know your name
[Music]